emilio estevez has had his share of ups
and downs in film and television
something that's bound to happen when
you start an acting career as young as
he did
at the tender age of 11. after scoring a
couple of roles in the 70s estevez's
star began shining brightly against the
backdrop of hollywood in the 1980s
he starred alongside a who's who of
upcoming stars and the outsiders and had
the lead role of otto in the nihilistic
comedy repo man estevez reached official
heartthrob status when he played high
school jock andrew clark and john uses
the breakfast club
then starred in another 80s
coming-of-age staple saying elmo's fire
by the time he starred in 1992's the
mighty ducks as compulsory hockey coach
gordon pompe
estevez had definitely carved out a spot
for himself in the entertainment world
between his time as a member of the brat
pack and the face of the mighty ducks
franchise
estevez dove into the waters of the
horror genre a script landed on
estevez's doorstep for a feature
projected to be a defining horror hit to
the 1980s
stephen king the master of horror wrote
the source material the movie is based
on and he was also attached to direct
the film
there's no way it could fail right
unfortunately the film didn't live up to
expectations flopping at the box office
and bombing with critics
years after the movie's release emilio
estevez finally revealed how he felt
about it
he has serious regrets about maximum
overdrive by the mid-1980s stephen king
was on top of the world the horror
novelist's books were turned into films
almost as quickly as he finished writing
them he could already name over a dozen
of his stories that had hit the big
screen including carrie
cat's eye fire starter and director
stanley kubrick's the shiny
when hollywood approached king to direct
his own feature film why wouldn't he
accept the offer
king penned the script to maximum
overdrive basing it on his own 1978
short story trucks
published in his short stories
collection night shift trucks tells the
story of a group of strangers stranded
at a diner fighting off self-aware
machines that have turned on humanity
sounds like a great premise for a horror
movie right unfortunately king's
creative talents didn't translate to the
silver screen as the director of maximum
overdrive the film received scathing
reviews and king was nominated as worst
director for that year's razzy awards
all right purpose stickers
hindsight is 2020 and in an interview
for tony mistraily's book hollywood's
stephen king the author admitted he had
no idea what he was doing as a director
king also confessed he was under the
influence of cocaine throughout nearly
the entire production of maximum
overdrive which offers a new perspective
on the film but he also noted that he
considers the whole thing to have been a
good learning experience
stephen king's realization about his
mistakes and maximum overdrive may have
been a relief from emilio estevez who
has similar feelings about the movie
during a march 2021 interview with
vanity fair to discuss estevez's new
disney plus series the mighty ducks game
changers
writer julie miller asked estevez about
his biggest acting regret
the actor named maximum overdrive is the
movie he looks back on and wonders why
he ever participated in
he said i'm not speaking out of class
because he knows it's a terrible movie
but stephen king often talks about his
one directorial experience on maximum
overdrive which i was in
the few times that i've connected with
him over the years he's like can you
forgive me for that
although the film failed to live up to
anyone's expectations we can at least
acknowledge that the music featured in
it holds up
legendary rock group ac dc produced the
maximum overdrive soundtrack
i'm in the mood for some music 80s
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you